bring in Chris Mannix who joins us and
Chris I know you said keep an eye on
this and you were right
why was there such a discrepancy on this
judges scorecard with this fight well I
mean as you know Dan my predictions
usually get on don't know why you're
surprised by by rarity of this but why
was there discrepancy I don't know you
did I mean a delay birds gonna have to
explain it
she's definitely gonna have to explain
it to the Nevada Commission bob bennett
told me he's the executive director of
the Nevada State Commission I he told me
he will sit down with her and go over
her scorecard but even he admitted that
she was wide tonight the question I I
had coming in Dan was why would she
assigned to this fight in particular I
have personally been at several fights
where significant fights where she has
been a judge and some of her scores have
been outrageous I mean just why beyond
what you even come close to to expecting
about a year ago top ranked the other
for another promoter they tried to get
her booted off a show involving one of
their star fighters because they were
uncomfortable with her her scoring in
some of these fights so my question to
the Nevada Commission one that they just
can't answer is why would she put on on
this show to begin with their position
is they believe that she's one of the
best judge they have I would be mainly
dispute that and point to the evidence
that is that that shows up all over the
place in high-profile fights as examples
of why how did you score this fight I
had even I thought I thought the
Canelo's strategy was unorthodox to
fight against the ropes
but I thought he landed more power
punches and the coffeeboxx numbers
played that out it was 114 110 when it
came to power punches so I thought
Canelo did enough especially in the
later rounds he could conceivably give
Canelo the 10th 11th to 12th rounds and
I think I gave him at least two out of
those three at the finish so I think he
did just enough to even the score I know
that they don't want us to talk about
the judging they want us to talk about
the actual fight itself and I think
you'll Renard
if you're a true boxing fan you were
entertained by what you saw but you
can't help it you have to factor in how
it was scored and then you also have to
factor in well it's boxing you have no
governing body here and we're gonna have
another rematch here and you're gonna
have triple G beat 36 years of age
fighting Alvarez who's what 27 gonna be
28 is this what we want is this great
this could have been a great night for
boxing was it a great night for boxing
well no it wasn't great and it wasn't
great because of the judging was a very
good night for boxing and I'm still
interested in a rematch I still think
that golovkin has enough left of the
tank to be and most people see the
ringside I mean I told you I had it even
but a lot of people around me had
golovkin by a point I know the HBO
broadcast had golovkin reasonably wide
so I think a lot could summon enough in
a rematch to win and that's that's an
expected one but you know promoters and
I sat there the press conference after
with danwon the promoters of the fight
you know we're begging the media to
write about the fight and not that the
judging you know put it bluntly they
could shut up I mean it's their
responsibility before a fight to lodge
protests when it comes to a judge like
this why is it that an idiot like me can
do a Google search and find that that
this judge has been protested before and
has had issues raised about her in the
past and these promoters who get a list
of prospective judges weeks before a
fight is made they don't notice her name
on there and say hello maybe not maybe
we need to take her out of the running
here so I have a problem with them I've
also got a problem with the Nevada
Commission I mean there is no rating
system nationally for boxing judges
which is insane in the NBA you know when
they take the 14 best referees during
the year and they make them the referees
of NBA Finals games why is the Nevada
Commission which is the preeminent
Commission all of boxing why do they not
have a national ranking system and
failing that did when the fight was over
I said blanket techsmith's to personally
everybody in boxing I know to ask them
to name the three best judges that they
could name virtually all of it came back
with four or five
the same names guys like Steve Weisfeld
and Max DeLuca Burt Clements why is it
that Nevada that all these people have
the same opinion of great judges and the
Bata cousin why won't a vie to go out of
state and choose the best judges they
can find worldwide for the best where
the biggest fight that they're putting
on I guarantee you bob bennett that the
director there he did not want to be
standing in front of me in the aftermath
of that fight explaining why one of his
judges was terrible why do these guys
not go not not putting far more effort
to determine who the best judges are and
put them in positions of power on these
biggest night you're fired up aren't you
it was just it's it's too predictable
then it's too easy again i as you know I
get a lot of things wrong but this was
like you it's like you walk into it you
say that Judge it's that wide scorecards
in the past questionable decisions why
is she doing this why are we why is
judging overruling this and again if I'm
Gennady golovkin I wake up this morning
after my face is still bruised my hands
are still bruised I'm wondering what my
team was doing where was my team
watching my back where was my manager
where was my promoter if everybody in
the media knows that this judge is
capable of a questionable decision
why was my promoter why was my manager
not protecting me in this moment
have you been to bed yet that's like two
hours on a plane and then hard to sleep
you don't get the first class up great
stuff mmm hope you got a problem middles
middle seat and coach there that would
how quickly is there gonna be a remit
Alvarez only fighting on May and in May
in September so at the very earliest and
most likely I think it'll be made that
the financial sides of it are largely
understood on both sides just it just
begs the question if Alvarez wants to
take an interim fight in between or if
he wants to go straight for the galapiat
a rematch golovkin team is already
pushing for that may fight so hopefully
we see it made during Cinco de Maya
weekend thank you Chris
you got it Dan that's Chris Mannix NBC
sports radio Yahoo's the vertical covers
the NBA as well as boxing the Dan
Patrick show week
on audience